let's jump over to the physical
manifestation we have this story from
American experiment.org I'm not familiar
with this organization but they do have
a graph showing the change in population
among states and it's a little hard to
read because everything's kind of small
but you can see here California at the
bottom losing 367 299 people New York
352 000 185 followed by Illinois at 122
460 and then Massachusetts at 46 and so
on and so forth you can then see the
states that gained the most population
Florida 220 thousand eight ninety taxes
170 000. the interesting thing is the
people fleeing nuke in California are
actually spreading Out Among many of
these states now I don't think there's a
one-to-one ratio for the most part it
could be that some people are just
leaving the country outright but it's
very obvious isn't it Florida has one of
the biggest cities in the country Miami
but they're seeing population growth so
it's not a city-sized issue Texas it's
one of the biggest states in the union
and they got some of the biggest cities
they're seeing population growth so it's
not that people are fleeing big cities
or blue cities it's that people are
fleeing totalitarian States for freedom
this is a manifestation of everything
we're seeing going on people are voting
with their feet they're saying I'm mad
as hell I can't take it anymore
and they're moving
it's a tough move to be completely
honest especially you know you've got a
family you got to find a new job
but I'll tell you what worries me about
all this maybe worry isn't the right
word maybe maybe I should say
what I noticed is that we are now seeing
that ideological polarization become
geographical polarization
people are going to say no to Newsome
and to how do you say your name hokel
hochul
I don't know whatever good people are
going to play this stuff and I'm worried
about what happens next when you then
have a city that is 99 Democrat and
another city that is 99 Republican and
they're just going to be like y'all
aren't welcome here right they're you're
gonna have that social contract you were
mentioning just a moment ago where one
group says we don't serve that other
group of people but now it's at the
state level but it's even happening
between blue States like you were saying
earlier like Union City New Jersey you
can't go into the city like they've been
doing their whole lives because New York
City is essentially saying you're not
welcome here and you're chill your
five-year-old's not welcome here unless
you do what we say and you soon might
not be able to travel to those
particular States right as interstate
travel could be vax mandated soon which
is oh yeah people have been they've been
talking about putting up state borders I
mean they sort of this sort of happened
last year when police had checkpoints
between Connecticut and New York because
they were worried about New Yorkers
fleeing to Connecticut
but it might I I think we actually might
see it happen I mean uh Europe to a
certain degree has had some border
checkpoints but that's because they're
like we're countries not states the U.S
hasn't had that what which amendment
does it that allows freedom of movements
at the 14th
you can freely move between states the
the right to travel is pulled I think
it's under the 14th Amendment but yeah
it's I I think the essence of it is one
of the Liberties right uh that the
states cannot I wouldn't want to be in a
state like I don't know California it's
a court invented Doctrine the right to
travel but yeah but the thing with
California it's not necessarily just a
totalitarianism although that does play
a role in the thing about Dimension it's
just not being able to afford to live
you literally just can't afford to live
in California right now in in California
it's I think a much longer Trend than in
some of these other places
um in California there's a vicious cycle
where the middle class is being pushed
out it's impossible to live in
California increasingly as a middle
class family
um as a combination of of uh sort of
economic benefits and detriments uh
California is becoming extremely
polarized between very wealthy people
who can afford the costs and then a
dependent class of poor people who are
dependent on the state and the programs
um that's a much longer term Trend in
California although I'm sure it's
accelerated now but I'm not sure how
much like for example and it's not
population normed so it's hard hard to
say like California is just a much
bigger State it's a smaller percentage
of people
um you know could could result in a very
big bar graph but my my impression is
that California has faced this problem
for a quite a few number of years even
before covid and particularized on the
middle class which makes the political
situation worse because the middle class
is the Republican base in California so
like the politics are becoming more
unidirectional Extreme as the middle
class is getting pushed out and it's
probably why their borders are wide open
as well so they could fill in the void
a huge tax this is like 10 or 15 years
ago
um they they discussed what would be
wildly unconstitutional but they
discussed essentially a seizure of half
of your assets and when you exit the
state to try to keep stuff from leaving
oh yeah well it was like up to 10 years
after you leave they could tax you it's
like good luck sending your tax agents
to my state it's important though
Florida has 21 million people in
California has 39 million so California
if you were to normalize you know for
population California's losing a lot of
people relative to what Florida is
gaining you can also take a look at some
of these other states that are small
like Mississippi or Maryland when
Maryland loses 19 871 people Maryland
doesn't have that many people relative
to California so you got to understand
population density as well people are
fleeing these blue lockdown States for
non-lockdown States for the most part
not completely but for the most part
so I see DC is very small in comparison
even to all the states so I I would
guess that if you Norm is by population
you would see DC be on par if not
beating out New York and California for
fleeing especially since the the barrier
to leaving in DC is so much lower
because you can just move across the
state line and still keep your job keep
your commute keep your everything DC is
692 000 people
so yeah so we yeah
um I'm not going to plot a calculator
and do the normalization but you know
you get the point I was trying to see
where New Hampshire was on the list but
it has a very small population but it's
gained I think around 13 000 people
that's pretty significant look we we
lived I lived in New York and I told
people I was getting out because I saw
how bad things were getting politically
look where they are now and then I moved
to Jersey and then it was still bad with
the bombings and the police killings
moved to South Jersey and then the riots
happened they crossed the bridge and I
said I'm going to Mill nowhere yeah I
moved out of New York City as well I ca
I couldn't handle it I was like this is
absolutely crazy to be living in there
like I don't know
well I moved from DC so there you go all
right it's an improvement it's an
improvement um from a swamp to a rat
infested
I I love New York City
um despite some of the crazy politics
I've never lived really in a place where
I agreed with the majority of my
neighbors
um but I think in terms of this this
moving and the decisions that people
were making about
um you know geographically becoming more
stratified
I think the real key would be using like
what you guys are doing right using that
move to build something new to build
those networks because a lot of these
forces are National right if if
everybody moves to West Virginia even if
they don't bring their liberal politics
with them even if it's only conservative
for example or people who oppose
lockdowns or whatever it is moving to
West Virginia a lot of these forces are
National West Virginia is 20 years
behind in terms of being you know sort
of shaped to your point about the shades
of your point about shades of moving
from yellow to white as a background
color you know if if these moves are
losing
I I think that they still control when
you you still have a corporate media
control you have control of your
bureaucracy National bureaucracy you
have control of most of the culturally
producing institutions not the least of
which are the academy and the K-12
schools so for example even in red
States public schools and the district
officials are at least a standard
deviation or two right left of the
population this is why things move
entire States even red States left over
time this is why the left is so freaked
out about the rights assault on critical
race Theory because progressives don't
have children they have yours I remember
who told us that but it's a good point
yeah conservatives have way more kids
than liberals and Liberals are more
likely to abort their children meaning
if you just went by Family you would
have substantially more conservatives in
20 years and the states would be turning
red however the left probably
understanding this has sought to
indoctrinate the children of more
conservative leaning people with
conservatives now figuring out what's
going on with critical race Theory this
complete completely threatens everything
about the left they don't have kids and
I'm not making that stand up I've done a
bunch of Stories on this back in 2000
there were several studies one found
that a couple of them found
conservatives had more kids than
liberals conservatives are having 2.05
replacement levels and liberals were
having like 1.5 meaning they weren't
what do we get today few research
showing that Generation Z is a teeny bit
more conservative for the first time in
a hundred years a generation is a teeny
bit more conservative because it's
always been shifting more Progressive
it's not because kids are you know
getting woke are getting red pilled or
getting woke or whatever it's because
there's more conservative families who
had more conservative kids but if the
the leftists get their way with critical
race Praxis in schools then the kids of
conservatives will become leftists and
they will continue to expand their
ideology I wonder if that shift has to
do with the fact that an increasing
percentage of conservatives are not
sending their kids into public school
but I I mean I I have to lay this one at
the feet of the right um I said I'm a
conservative so on my own sort of tribe
or whatever
um this is the natural result I mean
William F Buckley wrote God man in Yale
70 years ago and exactly none of of the
Republican party's political Capital has
ever been Advanced uh to do a damn thing
about education and this is the result
of Decades of saying oh ha ha you know
the blue-haired woke kids when they
graduate an impact with the real world
they'll figure out how to make a dollar
and they'll realize all this crazy stuff
that they're doing on campus is just
wacky well of course all those kids now
work in HR departments in Nike and they
work in you know agencies in the federal
government and they work in you know
whatever all the other institutions
media Hollywood right this is this is an
idiotic concept that you can turn over
the entire education system to one side
of the culture war and focus on whether
the taxes are lower or higher like
that's not good I'm in favor of low
taxes but that's not going to matter if
your entire generation we have now a
generation and a half of kids who have
learned even way before critical race
during the previous iteration of you
know 1619 that even even the standard
textbooks when I was in high school in
the mid-2000s those textbooks are
already skewed left this is not a new
problem this is and I frankly blame the
right for it even more that I blame the
left we have ignored this problem we
have put absolutely zero political
Capital into solving it and we've we've
that we're now reaping the the
consequences of that but even when there
is an effort to create a school like a
charter school let's say that is going
to you know not allow that kind of stuff
they ultimately do get infiltrated by
the woke teachers who do bring on their
woke stuff like I remember talking to a
handful of teachers at a charter school
in San Diego the charter school is
thriving it was doing great and it was
only a matter of time before the
teachers came in they started teaching
things that weren't in the curriculum
teachers were called on it then the
teachers started to unionize and then it
became a disaster the grades dropped and
now the schools become kind of a gang
Zone look okay so Charter Schools or
public schools first of all but this is
happening even in private schools
because again you can't allow ninety
percent of kids to go through what is
essentially a political indoctrination
and imagine that that the rest of
society is going to stay neutral on that
so what's happening is because we
allowed this problem to percolate for
for decades and now I mean look I'm
really glad that this is now on the
Republican agenda in a serious way
largely thanks to pissed off parents who
for the first time when they had Zoom
School actually listened to what's being
taught in in their kids social studies
classes right that that I cannot
describe to you how many parents I've
met who are like I had no idea
it was this bad until I actually
listened to what was being taught so in
that sense I think there's a silver
lining if there's a silver lining of the
school closures that have caused so much
Devastation it's that so many parents
have gotten a front seat to how bad the
indoctrination actually is in a way that
it's really hard to convince parents you
know if they read like a news story or
they see a video they say oh like that
happens in that town but that's not
happening in my town yes it is even in
the red States even in deep red counties
it is happening yeah in West Virginia
the school boards were infiltrated by
leftists by I'm not saying this to be
cute or to be hyperbolic actual marxists
who actually talk about Marx and support
Marxist views and these West Virginian
parents are alike but we live in West
Virginia it's like well look at a
certain point I think older Millennials
mostly Boomers and Silent generation
they just thought they won they were
like we did it we won America's done and
then they left and then leftists were
like okay let's go run for school board
let's go run for city council let's
start passing these things because
they're all asleep and not paying
attention that is exactly what happened
after the Reagan Revolution right
um the Reagan Revolution essentially
people said okay we
um we have won a bunch of political
victories
but they focused on the political
victories they forgot about the culture
and what actually happened is all of
those 60s and 70s radicals went and
became professors in the universities
they went and became teachers in K-12 to
your point about charter schools and the
the sort of influx it's that there's
this same bunch of Consultants there's
the same bunch of teacher training
certified teacher trainings the
certification itself the schools of
Education are the most left-wing parts
of left-wing universities right
um the there are National this is kind
of my point there are National
institutions involved here and every one
of those National institutions is
co-opted they're all infiltrated they're
all you know bought into this ideology
so if anything moving to a red state if
you're not actively building alternative
institutions to compete that's not
helpful and you can build those
institutions even in a blue state so I'm
not saying like I think it's fine that
people are moving things for a lot of
people it's a great decision it's a
right decision but I think if you're not
if you're sort of moving and becoming
complacent and saying oh I live in a red
State now I don't have to worry about
these crazy you know indoctrinators or
whatever you are wrong you were you were
talking about the importance of building
culture too though can you build culture
in those places I I was specific in my
words for a reason
um I think culture is the essentially
the product of that right all of those
those institutions and those networks
you always have individualists you
always have people who disagree right I
went through Public School my whole life
um but I I just think that to imagine
that the education system has no impact
on the political environment when those
kids grow up and and go get jobs and and
vote and participate in society is
ludicrous of course it matters that's
why the left cares so much about it well
that's what we're trying to do in West
Virginia you know if you look at the
little chart here West Virginia isn't
one of these states that has seen the
most growth and I think that is perfect
I don't want it look I like Florida and
I like Texas we went to Texas as
students we uh I've lived in Florida
before it's also too dance I've looked
at property in both it's ridiculously
expensive and you get very little land
West Virginia in my opinion has the
freedom not as perfect I think Florida
New Hampshire do a bit better in that
regard but it's got a small a lower
population density an excellent
opportunity to build culture create an
economic space bring more life to this
particular area and these values of the
people who are here second amendment
constitutional carry Freedom Liberty
individualism responsibility all that
stuff I'm for it so we'll build cultural
around that and that will create an
economic Center maybe not the biggest in
the world maybe not the biggest ever but
big enough that will help people with
these positions with these policy
positions uh grow and succeed and have
families to the you also have to harness
the actual so it's not I I'm in total
agreement with everything that you said
but you can't completely forget public
policy in fact West Virginia after
um you know this state was one of the
last holdouts in terms of school choice
private school choice in in the country
because there's a very powerful like the
they're not really unions but the
teachers the teachers unions here
functionally
um have enormous power hour and we're
able to block those bills year after
year after year in the Republican
legislature even right even after the
changeover when all the Democrats
essentially became Republicans here
um but now you have an education savings
account program here you have the
largest education savings account
program in the country in a state where
just a year and a half ago you couldn't
pass a tiny school choice program for
kids with special needs because the the
Dynamics have changed so overwhelmingly
in these debates I think that that's a
really positive sign so it's individual
building networks being building new
institutions but it's also not
forgetting that public policy is an
important tool and we shouldn't you know
cut ourselves off from availing
ourselves of that tool personally I'm a
Florida man at heart I think there's a
big fight that's going to happen in that
purple state where there's a lot that
kind of ways for the future of this
country but also I think another big
victory that that we should kind of talk
about is is more people homeschooling
than ever homeschooling networks also
becoming more prominent people coming
together and saying hey these
institutions have failed us we could
teach our kids on our own uh and and
sharing resources sharing uh
Professionals in the field and and then
being able to to sit at home and
actually raise their children as they
want without any state indoctrination uh
because essentially if you look at
Education Centers I mean one they're
outdated they were created by the
Rockefeller system that was trying to
create literally Factory workers uh it's
nonsensical and a lot of the stuff that
they teach them it's not only just
brainwashing but a lot of it is also
impractical they could be learning real
life skills in the real world if people
take time to homeschool uh their
children and I think that's one of the
best things you could do in this life by
by helping raise the future of this
country so formally legally there's
always a separation on the usually on
the request of homeschoolers between
education savings account programs and
homeschooling because they don't want
any a lot of people just don't want any
money coming in from the government but
you can build something very similar and
it allows a lot more people to build
something of that way so for example in
Florida where they do have an Esa
program that's pretty well established
you have families building what they're
calling micro schools where you just
have 10 families who pull their money
from this education savings account
program that sends a portion of estate
funds that they would have spent in the
public school to the family directly and
you see parents actually you know doing
something really amazing that they're
finding other people who who are sort of
like-minded about what education they
want to give their kid and and they're
pooling that money and essentially
creating a small school and that's
that's really what modern homeschooling
oftentimes looks like it's co-ops it's
it's I think a lot of people have an
idea of homeschooling that essentially
hasn't been true since the 90s right
it's very collaborative it's very like
social people say oh like I want my kid
to be socialized modern homeschooling
has a lot of co-ops it has a lot of
um you know sort of groups and
activities where kids from different
homeschooling families get together so
so in terms of practical as opposed to
Legal there's a very sharp legal
distinction but practically I think that
esa's open up something that looks a lot
more like modern homeschooling for a ton
more families yeah and there's been a
lot of attacks against homeschooling and
this larger idea that it's insular that
you're going to be home they're not
going to be socializing that idea is
absolutely lost and absolutely stupid
New Hampshire has a huge network of
homeschoolers and New Hampshire I
believe has one of the highest IQs per
state per capita than almost anywhere
else in the United States so I I think
that speaks true to the effect that
people are having when they're coming
together uh in areas like New Hampshire
like in Florida and and are saying hey
when it comes to raising a child this is
something that's important that we can't
just leave up to random strangers when
you do that bad things happen and I
think this is why we have such a big
problem in this country because too many
people relied on these institutions that
are corrupted well even if you rely on
somebody else to teach your child the
responsibility is always with the
parents and we've seen we saw that play
out in the Virginia election right where
McAuliffe is literally was straight up
saying parents have no right to to
decide on what their children learn in
public schools which is ludicrous right
um but that's that is the ludicrous
position that you end up with over time
when that cultural memory of parents
being the primary educators of their
children even if they then hire someone
to do the job for them that primary
responsibility still lies with the
parents and I I'm really I'm hopeful on
this I think I think that parents are
recovering that you know power of
sitting in the driver's seat of their
children's education and not you know
thinking that because there's a bunch of
experts bleeding that you need a PhD uh
you know in child development in order
to teach your kid math like the I think
parents are really like waking up to the
fact that those institutions have seized
a lot of power from parents and that
they're trying they're they're
determined to get it back thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time